- Can you file a lawsuit in
the form of a comic book?
Well, the answer is apparently yes.
In a case in Texas, a suit
between a comic book store
and a hotel next door, there
was a third amended complaint.
So the plaintiff apparently
filed some motions
saying that they needed
more clarification.
And in response to that, the
plaintiffs got really cheeky
and they filed their complaint
effectively as a comic book.
Halfway through the complaint,
it basically just switches
to an illustrated comic
and they explain all of the events
that involve basically a
bunch of patrons in the hotel
throwing large metal
canisters off the hotel
and into the comic book store
in the form of a comic book.
Will this work?
That remains to be seen,
but it is hilarious
and incredibly interesting.
I've never seen this one before.
So we'll see this comic book in court.